bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est un
grand plaisir un grand honneur d'être
parmi vous aujourd'hui
on m'a demandé d'aborder
le rôle la question du rôle de la
culture dans la construction de
l'identité
je vais vous proposer de nous obtenir
une définition courante des termes
culture et identité car le temps manque
pour en déplier tout tous les aspects et
les problèmes que cela pose tant du
point de vue de la sémantique que de la
philosophie ou de la sociologie
d'ailleurs ce que je vais vous proposer
donc c'est de commencer cet exposé en
posant la question qui suis-je
alors bon vous avez une partie de la
réponse au tir mais ma tête
je suis sophie schaldach thoen je suis
maître de conférences à l'université de
bordeaux je suis anthropologue et je
fais des recherches en anthropologie à
partir d'un terrain que je mène au long
cours depuis une trentaine d'années à
wallis qu en polynésie occidentale au
coeur de l'océanie mais aussi dans la
communauté wallisienne en métropole
cette façon de présenter et partiel je
ne me présente la queue sous des aspects
qui sont à la fois sociaux et
institutionnels institutionnels parce
que la nomination est validée par l'état
civil
ma profession elle-même est validée par
un cursus qui est sanctionné par des
diplômes
le champ d'expertisé qui est le mien est
également le résultat de pratiques qui
s'inscrivent dans des normes à la fois
scientifique et professionnel et
académique
donc
c'est une façon partielle qui pourrait
être complétée si j'abordais
dès que d'autres aspects de ma personne
par exemple des aspects physiologiques
bon je vous apprendre pas grand chose si
je vous dis que je suis une femme mais
je pourrais vous donner mon poids ma
taille
vous vous donnez donc des aspects
de ma personne physique mais aussi des
aspects psychologiques par exemple la
conscience que j'ai de moi même et
notamment à travers la continuité de
l'expérience malgré le temps qui passe
c'est la même chose si
je fait état de la conscience de ma
présence aux autres et de ma ma présence
parmi vous aujourd'hui par exemple je
pourrais élaboré là dessus je pourrais
aussi élaboré sur mon histoire sur mon
expérience sur ce que je sais faire ou
pas faire sur ce que je ressens et tout
ceci en omettant toujours un certain
nombre d'informations de façon plus ou
moins délibéré consciente parce que
c'est les informations
dépendent systématiquement de d'une
sélection qui s'opèrent en fonction des
aspirations mais aussi de motifs
profonds et d'une pertinence
bref ce que je suis ne se résume pas à
ce que je dis pas ce que je montre de
moi parce que ce qui me construit en
tant que personne et infiniment plus
complexe et toujours changeant
lorsque c'est explicite et comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui
lorsque cela peut vous paraître évident
c'est toujours par rapport à un contexte
que nous partageons plus ou moins mais
qui est singulier
contexte et des enjeux par rapport à ce
contexte donc
j'ajouterai
qu'une part de mon identité se construit
aussi dans votre regard dans la façon
dont vous percevez ce que je suis et
dans ce que je perçois de votre regard
en retour comme un miroir un effet de
miroir est votre regard je peux y
adhérer me conformer mais je peux aussi
me confronter ne pas adhérer justement à
ce que vous percevez deux mois sous cet
aspect là l'identité est une
co-construction
alors puisque la question est ici celle
du rôle de la culture je vais tenter de
faire une réponse d'ethnologue
je vais laisser de côté ce qui est in et
j'ai pas les compétences pour ça pour
aborder avec vous ce qui est acquis et
ce qui est acquise se rassemblent en
deux grands ensembles qui
pour faire parler de façon un petit peu
général
qui correspondent à d'un côté ce qui est
transmis et d'un autre côté ce que nous
construisons au fil de nos parcours
alors pour commencer par ce qui est
transpire inculqué on pensait vide
évidemment tout de suite aux règles et
aux valeurs au corpus de connaissances
aux savoirs aux techniques plus ou moins
valorisés en matière de musique de danse
de dessins etc tels que l'éducation
nous les nous les procure
mais il ya aussi tout ce qui résulte de
notre socialisation ce qui s'impose à
nous par des phénomènes d'imprégnation
et de l'empt familiarisation ce qui est
assimilé de façon plus ou moins
consciente
ce que les anneaux log appel l'habitus
c'est un grand mot mais qui désigne
notre aisance à nous comporter selon des
normes qui sont propres à notre
entourage et en maîtriser les pratiques
quotidiennes par exemple se tenir à
table et est utilisé de façon appropriée
efficace une fourchette ou un stylo ou
un clavier d'ordinateur
ça fait l'objet d'un apprentissage sur
plusieurs années
tous ces micro gestes ses routines ses
habitudes des normes incorporez qui sont
à la fois personnelles parce qu'on se
les approprient mais aussi culturel
parce que c'est lié au contexte culturel
qui nous entoure à cet égard une
remarque importante toutefois c'est
c'est tous ces éléments de culture qui
nous sont transmis ne nous conditionne
pas pour autant on n'est pas prisonnier
de notre culture loin de là nous sommes
toujours engagés dans des processus
d'évaluation et d'ajustement qui nous
laisse des marges
par exemple pour ce qui relève des
salutations
le fait de regarder son interlocuteur
dans les yeux peut être interprété
différemment selon les contextes mais
aussi selon les cultures dans certains
cas c'est une marque de respect dans
d'autres cas ça peut être une une forme
d'impertinence voire de défis donc on
est toujours
en train de se dévaluer les situations
et de voir comment 6 ce agir au mieux en
fonction de la situation
ici la relation à notre environnement
est essentiel et ici aussi il faut
inclure la relation aux autres qui par
leurs encouragements leurs félicitations
mais aussi leur réprobation des fois
leurs sanctions vont nous guider dans
notre évolution et vont nous aider à
agir correctement en prenant conscience
de la place qui nous est assigné dans un
collectif donné les collectifs peuvent
varier mais aussi de noisettes notre
existence en tant qu elle prend racine
dans des interactions avec un entourage
plus ou moins large
j'en viens à ce que nous construisons on
vient de voir ce qui est transmis
par inculcation
là
j'en viens à ce sur quoi nous sommes
plus activement engagés au fil de nos
parcours singulier et tout au long de
notre vie ce qu'on peut considérer comme
étant une forme de réalisation
personnelle qui peut être en partie
indépendante de la culture avec ses
dimensions psychique psychologique
dans c'est ce qu'on peut classer dans ce
registre il ya évidemment les
connaissances que l'on se forge tout au
long de notre vie des différentes formes
d' expertise de talent de savoir-faire
de compétences aussi qu'ils sont plus ou
moins reconnus institutionnalisé des
intérêts qu'on va développer des
sentiments que vont générer des
rencontres des événements dans lesquels
on va se trouver impliquer toutes ses
dispositions
ces savoir faire techniques plus ou
moins spécifique qui tout en étant
développés selon des normes vont
répondre à des attentes à des buts
délibéré que nous nous nous nourrissons
qui ne sont pas nécessairement imposée
de l'extérieur et on retrouve là aussi
notre capacité à évaluer des situations
à s'y positionner en fonction de règles
de normes d'enjeux comme tout comme
c'est le cas pour ce qui est transmis
mais à un autre niveau là le niveau est
celui des connaissances et des
compétences en tant qu'elles sont
délibérément acquise entretenu afin de
mieux maîtriser notre action pour
parvenir à nos buts et et satisfaire nos
besoins donc là on est dans le registre
d'une action intentionnelle
délibéré dans ces deux cas la culture et
centrale elle consiste le plus souvent
dans je voulais dit à plusieurs reprises
des normes des règles des conventions
plus ou moins explicite mais aussi dans
des institutions locales excusez moi
dans des institutions sociales
on pense à l'école à la famille aux
associations sportives par exemple mais
aussi on oublie souvent là le langage et
la langue dans laquelle nous sommes
socialiser d avant notre naissance in
utero mais aussi
dans laquelle nous communiquons
régulièrement avec laquelle nous
interagissons avec notre entourage par
ce moyen on dit le monde on échange à
son sujet on raconte ce qui nous arrive
et ce faisant en us de construction
narrative qui met en lien des événements
qui sont souvent disparates on met en
lien aussi des événements avec nos
émotions on met en lien des rapports
dont on construit des rapport de cause à
effet entre des événements par exemple
des événements et des émotions des
événements et des pensées etc etc
le langage c'est ce qui nous permet dit
d'unifier notre expérience en reliant
des faits et parce de différentes
natures par son intermédiaire on reçoit
aussi de l'information cette information
elle est organisée au moyen de mots et
de concepts sait moins c concept format
vocabulaire mais à travers ce
vocabulaire et les lexiques qui le
qu'ils organisent
les mots et les concepts constituent un
ensemble un univers de penser
d'idées qui sont plus ou moins stabilisé
sur la façon dont le monde se présente à
nous et dont nous les percevons
le langage et donc chaque langue
spécifique organise ainsi notre
expérience du monde et un certain point
au moins jusqu'à un certain point au
moins le monde tel qu'il est socialement
et culturellement organisée autour de
nous un exemple mais on pouvait en
prendre une infinité en fait
les les langues pose toutes les
phénomènes de traduction les tentatives
de traduction posent tous tout ce type
de problème envoi lysiens par exemple
oiseaux se disent manou l'ailé mais man
ou l'ailé en retour ne désigne pas que
les oiseaux mais aussi les chauves
souris donc on voit là des phénomènes de
des phénomènes d'inadéquation en tout
cas là en l'occurrence une idée une
inadéquation partial mais des phénomènes
d'inadéquation catégorielles en passant
d'une langue à l'autre c'est vrai pour
le français louis l'isère mais c'est
vrai pour le français et l'anglais etc
la plupart de ces contextes vous l'avez
compris on donc
une incidence importante sur nos dettes
notre développement en tant qu' en tant
qu'humain
et la langue et la un médiateur
essentiel l organisme mon expérience et
user d'autres langues
m'ouvre de nouveaux horizons de
nouvelles perspectives sur le monde mais
aussi sur ce que je peux en apprendre
nos paroles nos actions notre seule
existence au sein d'un groupe social par
ailleurs nous engage dans le monde
cet engagement dans le monde et
l'expérience qu'on en tire avec leur lot
d'échecs plus ou moins productifs vont
générer des compétences des
connaissances qui sont développés tout
au long de la vie au regard des
contextes particuliers
donc vous l'avez compris c'est contexte
ont des dimensions essentiellement
culturel et social nous ne vivons pas
dans un isolement total telle rue ben
robinson crusoé qui vit sur une île
déserte
on vivre on vit entre humains mais aussi
en contact étroit avec des objets et des
choses de l'environnement environnement
naturel mais aussi environnement
culturel en ce que ces objets ces choses
sont spécifiquement destinés à notre
usage à notre bien-être et à notre
survie là sur notre survie personnelle
mais aussi celle de notre de notre
groupe quel qu'il soit de nos groupes
donc vous le voyez la définition de
personnes et d'identité gagne encore en
complexité puisque selon les sociétés
les catégories alors qu'il s'agisse de
personnes et identité mais aussi du vin
de choses et d'objets qu'on vient de
voir ne trouve pas l'exact équivalent sa
supposée expérience différente du monde
et des formes de pensée qui sont
alternative à son sujet
donc la question du contexte culturel et
social est cruciale je pense qu'on peut
s'entendre là-dessus il présente des
variations en termes de perception
d'expérience et des conceptions qu'on
peut en tirer
tous ces phénomènes ne sont pas toujours
faciles à appréhender sinon par un
effort plus ou moins poussée de
réflexivité de mise à distance c'est
souvent la distanciation qui nous permet
de voir à quel point nous sommes
imprégnés de culture est constitué des
relations sociales qui nous traversent
ce que je veux dire là c'est que la
conscience aiguë que l'on peut avoir
d'une dissonance en matière de
perception d'expérience de
conceptualisations notamment des
sensations plus ou moins fugitive
d'inadéquation de perte de repères
de
d'étrangeté cette confiance cette
conscience aigüe surgit au détour d'une
expérience inhabituelle dans des
situations qui nous apparaissent
clairement où nous apparaît clairement
le poids des habitudes
des normes et des usages notamment des
usages du langage
ça c'est souvent le cas face à des
pratiques différentes à des à des façons
différentes de faire et de penser
face le fait de nous confronter
fait émerger de la perplexité des
interrogations qui montre à quel point
la confrontation avec l'altérité peut
être à la fois problématique mais aussi
enrichissante
sous cet aspect ce que l'on appelle les
terrains ethnographique pour revenir la
pratique professionnelle
c'est-à-dire des enquêtes de longue
durée fondé sur une fréquentation
assidue des gens avec qui on travaille
mais aussi les voyages et les échanges
interculturels
son formateur je suis moi-même partie
dans un
parcours
qui repose sur plutôt des échanges
interculturels ensuite des voyages et
puis ensuite une pratique un plus
professionnelle de sept de ses
techniques de distanciation de
décentrement
donc
ce sur quoi je veux insister c'est qu'il
n'ait pas d'expérience qui ne nous
transforme et en l'occurrence qui ne
nous ouvre à l'axé qui ne nous ouvre
l'accès à de nouvelles connaissances de
nouvelles perspectives sur le monde et
sur la façon dont il est peuplé
j'en viens à une conclusion qui
ramassent le propos
naître et grandir dans un monde social
dans une culture donnée est une
caractéristique qui est propre à notre
espèce en tant qu'humain mais l'univers
familier de la culture parce qu'elle cet
univers qu'elle forme autour de nous et
en nous ne nous en ferme pas
il est toujours possible de souffrir de
ce pardon il est toujours possible de
s'ouvrir à d'autres cultures et de s'en
laisser pénétrer
cette ouverture sur ce qui est différent
sur ce qui nous est inconnue peut-être
un détour qui nous enrichit qui aiguise
notre conscience à deux niveaux le
premier niveau qui est un niveau qu'on
peut considérer comme relatif une forme
de relativisme
et que cette ouverture renforce comme
retour la conscience du milieu naturel
et social qui fait de nous ce que nous
sommes
alors c'est ce qui résulte de nos choix
et nos aptitudes personnelles de notre
parcours toujours singulier mais
toujours
en ce qu'il se déroule dans le cas de
tradition familiale régionale nationale
des traditions aussi qu'ils peuvent être
professionnels qui peuvent être amical
institutionnels et qui nous situe dans
des formes d'héritage qui sont plus ou
moins conscient
mais à un autre niveau qui l'a plus
universaliste
cette ouverture
enrichit notre expérience et nous permet
d'approfondir notre compréhension du
monde
en cela accepter des différences qui
sont essentiels au développement de
notre humanité
nous permet de nous accomplir plus
pleinement en tant qu'être humain
voilà je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]